let's talk for a second about Puerto
Rico Elon Musk has said why in the world
would you rebuild an old-fashioned
electrical grid when you can put in
solar power can you talk to that well
you know John we don't work in in Puerto
Rico but we work in most of the
countries around and we've been very
involved in responding to that to the
hurricane we've got a lot of very
interesting instruments that have
released but here's what what's happened
just in my time at the World Bank Group
so five years ago I was told oh my gosh
it's so exciting solar is down to ten
cents a kilowatt hour right the last
auction that happened in Saudi Arabia
just last week price is now down to one
point seven cents a kilowatt hour so
just to give you a comparison in the
United States where we have relatively
cheap electricity is about 10 11 12
cents a kilowatt hour so solar now is so
inexpensive that it makes sense from an
economic perspective just about anywhere
and it's great that that Elon Musk said
it because Elon Musk is about to occur
in the next great revolution the problem
with the solar and wind is that if you
don't have the wind or the Sun then the
electricity stops so the key is battery
storage what we hear is that he's
working on lithium-ion batteries that
will be ten times cheaper and ten times
smaller so solving both the size and the
price problem with batteries means that
even on days that are not sunny you
would have stored so much energy in
those batteries that you have continuous
power so what he's talking about is now
the thing that we're pushing everywhere
for example in both China and India
they're moving aggressively toward
having more and more of their energy
supplied by solar because we know that
probably in a couple of years we're
going to be able to store massive
amounts of energy
much more than we ever were able to
before and so it's good news for the US
in a sense because it's you know now
last year was the first year I think
that that jobs in the renewable energy
industry were greater than jobs in the
traditional energy industry this is this
is a driver of economic growth in the
United States and we think that it
actually could be a win-win situation
for Puerto Rico and companies in the
United States